apple is about to make perhaps the
wildest move that they have
ever made to the macbook pro to
completely revolutionize
the laptop as we know it and they have a
master plan
on how to do this and we are the ones
who will benefit from it in this video
i'm going to talk about the future of
the macbook pro
based on what apple has already been
doing as well as some crazy leaks
rumors and recent patent filings which
show that apple is about to make
everyone happy all at once so before i
get into the leaks and all of that good
stuff
i want to quickly cover what apple has
already been doing
with their mac lineup that's been
getting a lot of people excited
back in november apple revealed the very
first apple silicon chip for the mac
which is of course the m1 chip and
despite the fact that they didn't change
anything else about the three macs that
received the m1 chip
people have been buying them up left and
right because they're much more powerful
and reliable
while using less power and being more
silent
apple did this by essentially taking the
more simple chip
technology from their iphone and ipads
and scaling it up
into a mac computer chip which makes it
much more efficient
than competing processors from intel and
amd
which use the totally different x86
architecture
which has been around for ages because
of that
apple has a massive advantage especially
in
the laptop space since that's where
efficiency matters most
and intel and amd are many months if not
years behind in terms of transitioning
into this type of chip technology
and even if they do catch up there's the
problem of their new arm-based chips
taking advantage
of the actual computer software or even
working at all
and that's a big problem because most
laptops use windows software
that's fully controlled by microsoft and
then
there's also the aspect of the laptop
manufacturer
who actually makes the laptop which ends
up utilizing both the chip
and the software but lucky for apple
they now
literally control everything from the
chip
the software and the laptop itself
so they have a huge advantage compared
to their competitors
and to make it even better they've been
slowly preparing for this apple silicon
chip transition
for a few years now like back in 2018
when apple killed 32-bit apps in mac os
they did this because they needed all of
the traditional x86 apps
to be 64-bit so that in the future
they could use their rosetta 2
translation software to convert them
into apps that support apple silicon
and that is why the new m1 max works so
incredibly well so the point of this is
that apple is
way ahead of their competitors and
they're only
just getting started the current m1 chip
packs an
8 core processor and 8 core graphics
and we've been seeing rumors of apple
designing macbook pro chips
with up to 20 processor cores and 32
graphics cores
which is absolutely insane if you
consider how powerful the m1 chip
already is with its limited amount of
course but for the
time being the next apple silicon chip
that we're expecting
is the m1x chip for the new 14 inch and
16 inch macbook pros
which are rumored to be coming this
summer and quarter three of 2021
and they should be getting at least 12
processor cores
and 16 graphics cores and we think that
it's going to be so powerful that it's
going to outperform
apple's 12 core mac pro in terms of
multi-core performance
and it's gonna match up to the latest
5300m graphics chip
in this 16-inch macbook pro so yeah the
future is extremely bright for the
macbook pro
in terms of the chip technology and the
software but i still haven't gotten
into the major changes that apple is
making
to the macbook pro to help it consume
the laptop market
so let's get right into it ever since
the 2016 redesign of the macbook pro
people have been complaining about a lot
of weird changes that apple made
like removing the beloved max save
charging system
and the switch to solely having usb-c
ports
forcing users to buy dongles and for the
past
five years apple has refused to budge
on any of the complaints from their
users but
now leaks and rumors are pointing to
apple finally having
a massive change of heart basically
going
all out and far beyond what we expected
for the next macbook pros coming this
summer so let's dig into it
we've recently been seeing a bunch of
rumors that apple is going to completely
redesign the macbook pro
flattening out the sides and the back
just like they did on the iphone
the ipad and the recent pro display xdr
so it totally makes sense for them to
bring this modern looking design
over to the macbook pro as well and
they're not stopping
at just the redesign they're taking this
opportunity to
literally fix basically every complaint
that people had
to make the best macbook pro of all time
for example we've seen many leaks about
apple replacing
the current lcd display that many people
are getting tired of
with a brand new mini led display which
is supposed to mimic
a great looking oled display but without
all the drawbacks
what's great about this is that mini led
what's great
what's great about this is that many led
displays are very thin
which will allow them to more easily
upgrade the outdated 720p
webcam which is something people have
complained about for years
another thing a lot of people have
refused to accept is the touch bar
a touch screen display which replaces
the top row of function
keys on macbook pros and now
rumors are pointing to apple finally
ditching it
and going back to regular function keys
and way back in 2016
apple completely removed the magnetic
magsafe charging system
and forced users to charge using one of
the usbc ports and
a lot of people were upset and now it
looks like they're bringing back
magsafe which came as a complete shock
to me
but i'm personally very excited because
my son just recently started walking
and he's already tripped over my
macbook's charging cable a couple of
times
and maxsafe would prevent this from
happening and on top of that
mark german says that the switch back to
maxsafe
will allow for faster charging speeds as
well
which is always nice digging even deeper
the most significant change that will
impact
the most people is the likelihood that
apple is bringing back
some of the most common ports that they
previously removed five years ago
just yesterday ming chi quo reported
that apple is not only bringing the
sd card slot back to the macbook pro but
also a physical hdmi port which i was
not expecting at all
so essentially the new macbooks later
this year will
be coming with four usb 4 ports a
headphone jack
an sd card slot a full hdmi port
and possibly a usb a port as well this
is going to be a huge deal for a lot of
people
since they will no longer have to use a
bunch of dongles or adapters anymore
so you might be asking why in the world
did apple wait
5 years to finally fix all of those
issues even going as far as to bring
back
a bunch of the ports the apple
previously said
were outdated basically showing that
apple was wrong
well i believe that apple has a master
plan
to take back a huge chunk of the laptop
market
and get their users to finally trust
them again and the way they're gonna do
this
is by fixing as many complaints from
their users as possible
to make every single customer happy and
willing to finally upgrade
to a new macbook pro and instead of
slowly doing this
over the span of a few years like they
usually do
they're going to unleash everything all
at once
and essentially create the best macbook
pro
or perhaps the best laptop ever made
ming chi kuo said that these practical
changes to the ports
specs and design will boost macbook
shipments
by 25 to 30 percent compared to last
year
which was already a great year for max
sales
if you think about it the new macbook
pro will not only
fix all of those issues and complaints
that i mentioned but they will also get
a huge bump in performance battery life
and reliability compared to previous
models
so i personally think that these 14 inch
and 16 inch macbook pros
are going to be so good that they're
going to be sold out for months
and they're going to trigger a
revolution forcing other laptop makers
to switch to using arm-based laptop
chips
but because of apple's head start with
their apple silicon chips
i think there's actually a pretty good
chance that macbooks will be the best
selling laptops
over the next couple of years partly due
to the huge wave of buyers
of these m1x macbook pros but also all
of the other big features
that we're expecting for the future so
let's get right into those
programmers have found code within mac
os big sur
pointing to face id finally coming to
the mac but i'm really not sure if it's
going to be coming later this year
or potentially next year on top of that
apple has been researching using
titanium
instead of aluminum for their macbook
pros to give them a more
durable finish so we could be seeing
that within the next couple of years
apple has also been rumored to be
working on dedicated graphics chips for
the mac
specifically for the imac but i'm almost
100 sure
that apple will be bringing that to the
macbook pro as well
but i'm not sure when that's going to
happen another interesting leak
came in the form of a patent which shows
that apple is considering having a
small display on each and every single
key on the keyboard
which will make changing languages for
different regions
incredibly simple for apple and it's
gonna allow you
to view shortcuts much more easily and
finally
there have been patents that apple filed
for showing some sort of smart connector
or wireless charging pads coming to
macbooks
which would allow you to connect and
charge other apple devices
so it's going to be interesting to see
how apple is going to pull that off
so those are all the changes that we
should be expecting for the future of
the macbook pro but i think that the m1x
14 inch and 16 inch models coming this
summer
are gonna totally blow a lot of people's
minds and
they're gonna be incredibly popular if
you enjoyed this video go ahead and tap
the like button below
and click the circle above to subscribe
so you don't miss
out on when we finally get these
macbooks into our hands
and if you disagree with any of my
viewpoints in this video
go ahead and comment down below thanks
for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you